لا يتعين عليك البحث عن المأساة في
غزة، فهي تجدك في كل شارع تتناثر فيه
القمامة والمياه الراكدة المقفرة والأصوات الصاخبة،
لذا فقد عبرنا للتو
الحدود إلى جنوب غزة، وهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نتمكن فيها بالفعل من ذلك
دخلنا إلى غزة منذ 7 أكتوبر ونحن
الآن نتوجه بالسيارة إلى المستشفى الميداني
الذي أنشأته الإمارات العربية المتحدة حتى
الآن، وقد أتاحت إسرائيل ومصر الوصول
للصحفيين الدوليين بجوار
المستحيل، ويمكنك أن ترى السبب وراء قيام
الجيش الإسرائيلي منذ 7 أكتوبر  تقول إنها
ضربت غزة بأكثر من
22.000 ضربة، وهو ما يفوق بكثير
أي شيء رأيناه في Modern Warfare من
حيث الشدة والشراسة،
ونحن حقًا نلقي
نظرة صادقة على ذلك
هنا على الرغم من القصف الإسرائيلي العنيف،
هناك أناس في الخارج
الشوارع حشد من الناس خارج أحد المخابز، أين
يمكنهم الذهاب إلى أي مكان آخر آمن في
غزة، اعتادوا أن يكونوا على حق في الملعب عند وصولهم إلى
المستشفى الإماراتي الميداني، نلتقي بالدكتور
عبد الله آلن،
ما إن تبدأ جولتنا حتى تبدأ سيارة
الإسعاف لدينا، هذه هي الحياة الحقيقية وهذه
هي  ما تسمعه طوال الوقت الآن
نعم على الأقل 20 مرة في اليوم على الأقل 20
مرة في اليوم وربما أكثر في بعض الأحيان أه
أعتقد أننا اعتدنا
عليه الشيء الوحيد الذي لم يعتاد عليه أي من الأطباء هنا
هو عدد
الأطفال الذين يعالجونهم
تشير تقديرات الأمم المتحدة إلى أن حوالي ثلثي القتلى
في هذه الجولة من الصراع كانوا من
النساء
والأطفال. تقول جنان، البالغة من العمر 8 سنوات، إنها كانت محظوظة بما
يكفي للبقاء على قيد الحياة بعد غارة جوية على
منزل أسرتها أدت إلى سحق عظم الفخذ لكنها أنقذت
عائلتها المباشرة.
إنها لا تتألم،
وهذا
جيد كانت والدتها هبة بالخارج عندما حدث ذلك،
ذهبت إلى المستشفى للبحث عنها، كما تقول،
وجئت إلى هنا ووجدتها
هنا، وأخبرني الأطباء بما حدث
معها وتأكدت من أنها بخير.
الحمد
لله قصفوا البيت الذي أمامنا
ثم منزلنا جنان تخبرنا كنت
جالسا بجانب جدي وجدي
ساعدني وعمي كان
بخير فهو الذي
أخرجنا لا
تبكي لكن دكتور أحمد  يقول الراعي إنه من الصعب
ألا أعمل مع كبار السن مثل
الكبار ولكن مع
الأطفال شيء يمس
قلبك يمس قلبك ويختبر
إيمانك
بالإنسانية بينما نغادر جنان يعود دكتور ألاك
بأخبار الضحايا الذين
وصلوا من الضربة للتو  قبل 10 دقائق،
حصلوا للتو على St أرسل الآن
شابين مبتورين أه من القنبلة فقط من اللعنة التي
سمعناها للتو من
القنبلة سمعنا للتو هذا ما
أفهمه، حسنًا، سيصلون إلى
مناطقنا الحمراء
من فضلك رجل و أ  صبي يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا يتم
تحريكه في كلا الطرفين المفقودين في
حالة محفوفة بالمخاطر ما اسمك ما اسمك
يسأل الطبيب الملاحظات المقدمة من
المسعفين ملطخة بالدم،
ارتجلت تورني
بضمادة منذ افتتاح المستشفى الميداني
أقل من 2  منذ أسابيع، كان المستشفى
ممتلئًا بالمرضى، وكان 130 سريرًا من أصل 150
سريرًا ممتلئًا بالفعل،
لذا دعني أفهم أنك الآن
المستشفى الوحيد الذي
لا يزال به بعض الأسرة، أعتقد ذلك نعم أو
ربما أنا متأكد جدًا من ذلك لأنهم
كذلك  أخبرني أه أحد المستشفيات
بسعة 200 أه
يستوعبون 1000 مريض حاليًا والمستشفى
المجاور لست متأكدًا تمامًا من أنه
قال مثل 50200 ربما يضم 400 إلى 500
مريض لذا في إحدى المرات اتصل
بي  قال لدي ثلاثة مرضى في كل منهم،
يرجى أخذ أي مريض وإرسال أكبر عدد
ممكن منه، أعني أننا هنا منذ 15 دقيقة
وهذا ما نقوله بالفعل، هذا
هو ما تسمعه،
وترى في كل سرير لكمة أخرى أقل
من  أمير البالغ من العمر عامين لا يزال لا يعرف
أن والديه وإخوته
قتلوا في الغارة التي شوهته
بالأمس، رأى ممرضة
تشبه والده، عمته نايا تخبرنا
أنه ظل يصرخ أبي أبي
أبي أمير لا يزال صغيرًا جدًا على
الفهم  الرعب يحيط به في كل مكان،
لكن اللاما البالغة من العمر 20 عامًا تفهم ذلك
جيدًا. قبل 10 أسابيع كانت
تدرس الهندسة في الجامعة
وتساعد في التخطيط لحفل زفاف أختها
اليوم، وهي تتعافى من
بتر ساقها اليمنى،
واتبعت عائلتها الأوامر العسكرية الإسرائيلية
وهربوا من الشمال إلى الجنوب ولكن
المنزل الذي كانوا يبحثون فيه عن مأوى أصيب
في
غارة جوية، العالم لا يستمع إلينا،
تقول لا أحد يهتم بنا، لقد
نموت منذ أكثر من 60 يومًا بسبب
القصف ولم يفعل أحد ذلك
أي كلمات إدانة يتم تسليمها
في
عرموش رفيعة ولكن هل يسمعها أحد
مثل حلب حلب ومار أوبال غزة
ستُدرج كواحدة من أهوال
الحرب الحديثة العظيمة، لقد أصبح الوقت مظلمًا بالنسبة لنا
لترك امتياز لا تتركه الغالبية العظمى من
الجازين  لدينا لمحة مختصرة من
نافذة على الجحيم تنتهي مع
فصل جديد في هذا الصراع القبيح الذي
يكشف عن المساعدة المطلوبة